assalamualaikum greetings of Peace
welcome to the Dean Shaw Media your
whole subscribe if you haven't already
Andrew Tate
Andrew yeah
in jail I focused on doing push-ups and
reading the Quran
focus on the push-ups and I will read
the Quran
thank you very much thank you
know about this case so far he's been
arrested not charged has been under
investigation for almost a year without
any formal charges two of the Witnesses
in the case say he's like family to us
and they've never filed any charges and
are adamantly trying to get the
prosecution to get them off the victims
list
the other two victims a stripper and a
prostitute were spotted somewhere in the
French Riviera partying while
correspondence between the two revealed
and plotting against the tape brothers
and praising each other on how good of
liars they are
and that they should win an Oscar and
get on Netflix love or hate the guy this
is beyond that what we want to know is
that right after Andrew Tate accepted
Islam and was slowly transforming his
life for the better
for the first time we see him
apologizing for past comments giving up
alcohol and on his way to give up
gambling and this is only weeks into
accepting Islam
did his reversion to Islam play any role
into the arrest and what's the history
of Islam in Romania that's what we want
to explore here today with
our next guest Dr Steph an academic
historian from the El mukad Dima
Institute here on the dean show
[Applause]
alone
peace be upon him this is our religion
Islam Islam this is the beach
and I was explaining how much respect I
have for the faith
[Music]
again on the show
I appreciate it thank you thank you for
being with us here to explore some of
this because you're a historian from the
uh okay my Institute
and you're somebody who's also very well
versed into the history of Europe and
beyond that so many people have on their
minds you know I'm going to start off
with this this clip here and this is
right before his reversion to Islam
and we'll kick it off from there Plum
fixes a lot of the problems that men are
currently facing the problems we're
discussing on this show Islam fixes all
of them right that's the first thing
about Islam and I'm not a Muslim right
if I had to choose a religion I would
because I live in an Orthodox Christian
country I go to the Orthodox Christian
Church I donate twenty thousand dollars
a month to the church the church the
church in Romania is very powerful and I
like having church friends so I give
them a lot of money right so I guess I'm
an Orthodox Christian but if I had to
bet on one religion as if I were bang on
the stock market for the future
you have to bet on this mom
because Muslims my brother in Islam
Eddie from the dean show is creating the
dean Center which is a Masjid and a
tower center which is going to help
non-muslims learn about Islam insha
Allah and the most beautiful thing about
this is that we can all be a part of
this we can all take part in earning
rewards from this simply by donating
whatever we can to make this a reality
which is beautiful let's do that all
right let's click this link let's donate
what we can and let's make this a
reality insha Allah
thank you
[Music]
yes all right so this is before he ended
up accepting Islam you can see him
talking about how he was giving so much
money to the Orthodox Church he was
rubbing shoulders also with some of the
prominent members there he liked that he
talks about being an Orthodox Christian
and then shortly after some time we also
had him on the program and that was
before he accepted Islam and then he
ends up
coming back after accepting Islam to
Romania and he had already been in under
investigation since April at that point
they brought him in for maybe a day a
day not even and then they let him go
but this time after he accepted Islam
it's interesting that they have not
released him since he got back into the
country and has been locked up ever
since
so we wanted to explore a little bit of
the history of Islam in Romania we hear
this term Dracula and other things so
see if this might have played a role
into it
again
um it is
um a very interesting topic and rotate
himself Romania Eastern Europe the
Balkans which actually borders to
Romania Romania is officially not really
a Balkan country however there are some
some definitions that put it as a Balkan
country together with Bulgaria former
Yugoslavia Albanian and so on so it is
pretty much in that area which we know
that was once part of the Ottoman Empire
but interestingly enough about entertain
entertaining the Tate Brothers we have
done actually a show sometime back with
regards to and rotate and his conversion
and it is very interesting to see that
indeed
everything before before he became
Muslim which is very recently by the way
just happened right some months ago if
I'm not mistaken
um when he became Muslim uh suddenly the
media
they were not really on his side before
however from the moment it became Muslim
it became even worse
um you see that people are really
suddenly they come out with some things
that happened years ago she explained
himself I do have we do have a common
friend actually
um who knows him from Dubai when he
accepted the faith in the Islamic Center
in Dubai and we know that things
happened that he was he admitted he
admits that many things happened during
his time before I became Muslim and they
was not really necessarily A
a guy who we admire to look back to so
but from the moment he accepted the
faith and he always showed admiration
towards Islam as he makes sure he
mentions this also in this in this clip
that he showed
he actually stopped drinking
um he stopped donating the money to the
church and Orthodox Church which is very
strong in the Orthodox countries as you
might know of course yourself seeing
that we come from this area originally I
myself I'm Greek and I know that the
Orthodox Church is extremely powerful in
the Balkans and in Russia and in Romania
and in these countries where the
Orthodox
Christianity is quite strong uh quite a
powerful powerful Institution
and he spent twenty thousand dollars as
we just heard on this institution and
for him to change that that of course
must mean quite something and for in all
those countries such as Romania it might
mean also losing uh one of their sheep
who actually were quite wealthy so there
are so many elements I don't even know
how to start where to start and where to
end but in child life we're talking
about Islam in Romania which is another
interesting topic again and he so
happens to be there I don't think that
he chose Romania for Islam obviously
because it's a minority tiny minority
religion actually it's not more than
0.30.5 percent of people around 60 70
000 uh followers of of Islam in Romania
however it has more than 700 years of
History Romania and Islam more than 700
years of History
foreign
of history with Islam with Islam so
before the Ottoman Empire even I mean
we're talking about uh the Ottomans
arriving in that area in the 14th
century onwards but even before that
time even before that time there were
Muslims in Rome in the area which was
Romania which didn't was not called
Romania at the time many people
misunderstand the issue in the Middle
Ages the countries that we call nowadays
Italy Romania Hungary Germany they did
not exist in the Middle Ages they had uh
there were city-states for example in
Germany or Romania was two uh
principalities
and uh I would have to think of the
other one is the one and the other one
there's Transylvania as well in there
which joined them later but the two main
the new principalities uh which made
Romania at that time became later
Romanian so
it's extremely important to see that the
uh these two counties that made
um this that are nowadays counties that
that that are part of Romania nowadays
um with that time just uh principalities
are run by Princess and these princesses
even later when the most when the
Ottomans came some of them even accepted
the faith became Muslims so it is
extremely important to see that Romania
had a close connection to Islam even
before the Ottomans arrived even three
to four hundred years before and this is
quite important I would like to make a
an important uh point out of this one
because people always believe that the
ball counts including Romania Hungary
and all these countries that were once
part of the Ottoman Empire just saw
Muslims from the moment that the
Ottomans arrived which is not true
tell me Dr Steph how much do you does
the church now play I know they have
some statistics where it's about over 80
to 90 percent of people there are
practicing Orthodox Christians and how
much does it play the church play a role
in the politics
um very I mean an orthodox country in
general uh
from starting in Russia actually and
going all the way down to the south
towards Greece all these countries
Serbia Greece Romania Bulgaria these are
all considered Orthodox Christian
Orthodox countries which means that from
the very beginning of these uh Institute
these these these nations that developed
especially out of the Ottoman Empire in
the 19th century these countries were
based on on on on on the institution of
uh the Orthodox Church the Orthodox
Church is the one that actually
um fought or was on the side of the
people when they were asking for
independence from the Ottoman Empire
when Russia was fighting uh the Ottomans
the Muslim Ottomans so the Orthodox
Church is a kind of identity for the
people living in that part of the world
in the Balkans are in Russia and so on
so more than as you said yes more than
86 87 are just read recently bill belong
to the Orthodox Church in Romania so it
plays an extremely important factor and
after the fall of Communism which
happened in 1989-90 Romania had to find
another identity during the time of
Communism Romania was a communist
country where religion didn't play a big
role however it was still a part of the
identity but it has become now the main
identity of the people who had to to who
left the the Realms of the of the
Communist Regime and now they are
basically Orthodox Romanians so it makes
it gives them a sense of identity and
understanding of each other so it plays
a big role so it plays a big role it
just reminds me and how to make a
contrast here because it's Romania's
time the church's time here to show if
they are truly practicing their
Orthodoxy and Christianity you know and
I'll start off with this story we have
so many of these stories one of them
comes to mind where the Khalif the
leader of the Muslims at the time
there's a cousin a prophet Muhammad when
there was a Jew
and you probably know the story I'm
paraphrasing it who Ali he was
um he wasn't in possession of a property
of his and then they went to uh one of
the judges there and the judge ruled in
the favor of the Jew
and this was just illustrating the and
now this is the head of state and the
head of state is going now in front of a
judge and you have someone who you think
you know just because he's Jewish for
example that it would he had no chance
to go ahead and to win but this is the
justice of Islam so Romania to really
again if Andrew Tate if he had done uh
things like they are they are saying
then you bring the witnesses you come
forward but he's being held investigated
since April with no formal charges and
then when they break down and you look
at you know you know case starts falling
apart to for would you say this is a
great time for Christianity there to
step up the church to step up and the
show really their Justice
um
it would have been had he still been
with them
again he was spending twenty thousand
dollars as he says himself before I
think had he been still part of the of
the church and the church
they would have for sure because we also
know another thing the Orthodox Church
is one of the richest institutions in
the world
so I'm very sure that they would have
been able in Romania to actually find uh
one or two or three lawyers uh who would
be on on his side and would be able to
get him out without a problem but now
seeing that he's a Muslim and he makes
uh he doesn't hide it I saw him in in
one of the interviews when he basically
spoke to a non-muslim and he the very
first thing he said was salaam alaikum
so he greeted a non-muslim uh Pierce
Morgan it was actually within with
salaam alaikum
um so you can clearly see that he
doesn't hide he he he he's a loudmouth
you know that he's being he likes
listening to himself most probably so so
he has a lot to say but that puts him
also in trouble and at this moment he's
he is really in trouble although there
is absolutely as you said there are no
charges now I don't really see that the
church is going to step in and help him
I don't think that at all
what else can you tell us about so you
had this area here you have a long
history you also talk about uh many of
the misconceptions many of the
deliberate attempts in history you know
that you were actually you were someone
who stepped out of that and that is what
helped you actually as a Greek now also
or a Christian you also were somebody
who was programmed to think a certain
way as someone coming up in the schools
with the negative propaganda against
Islam and then you start to really study
Islam study the history and you ended up
accepting Islam so do you think now now
there's some of these in this area here
are there still a lot of these myths
perpetrated you know in Bosnia obviously
if you're you're somebody is as a Muslim
the a lot of the the extreme serbs there
they'll call you Turk and they'll
um use some of these
um some of these terms and whatnot
because they're also programmed with
some of this history now that uh
negative stereotypes against Muslims is
this also the same thing is that I kind
of identical or is it at a whole
different level now in Romania because
you have more practicing Orthodox
Christians can you get kind of get us a
feel because I we can I can understand
in this area in the Balkans with um
because I have family from there but
what about in Romania is it kind of
similar the the atmosphere
uh very good question a very valid
question actually it is a bit different
um it is a bit different the situation
is not entirely as it is on the Balkans
I mean as I said Romania in general is
not considered being part of the Balkan
Peninsula it brought us to the Balkans
so it brought us to Bulgaria in the
South and Bulgaria is considered a
Balkan country and the Balkan Peninsula
uh in general According to some
definitions do include they do include
Romania but in general they don't
include Romania Romania and Hungary have
seen the Ottomans and have had an
influence
um even before the Ottomans by the
Muslims in Islam
the difference is that because they were
earlier they became they they got the
independence much earlier than many of
the other countries in the southern in
their southern borders such as Serbia
Greece Bulgaria
um they had a less time that they
actually had the Ottomans in the country
um they became earlier a Christian
Nation independent nation and they
became part of the Communist Bloc which
happened you know after the second world
war until very recently until 1989 and
1990. so people have were influenced
also by communist ideals and Communists
were not very
supportive of religion in general all
religion was something that for them was
all the same and we don't look at that
forget it so basically Romania was
really a country where they allowed the
minorities we must say that during the
time of communism
uh the Muslim minorities who mainly live
in the south south east in in an area
called dobrusha and in this area North
Dover is Northern Russia where many
Muslims still live
um some of their Turkish origin some of
them have
um An Origin which you might have heard
of the gypsies the Romas as they call
them nowadays
um and some others again have a Tata
background so and there are also some
rivers mashallah and this is quite
interesting that we have nowadays quite
a number of Romanian Rivers nowadays who
are making the dawa down there I've seen
myself also that they're printing the
Quran in Romania nowadays Distributing
it there is a bit I I would say if I
compare them to Greece or to Serbia I
think they are a bit more open-minded it
is a bit different it is a bit different
nevertheless it is the influence of the
church that actually tries to as it does
in every and all the other of those
countries it tries to tell them it tries
to sell them the idea that the Turks who
were there these Ottomans they call them
Turks and these Turks who were there
basically they um enslaved us and we had
no during the time that we were under
ottoman rule we couldn't develop as an
independent Christian or European nation
so they kept us back and backwards so
even in a way they actually justify
communism they say even communism is
nothing else but
um after the ottoman rule another
enslavement again which goes back to the
ottoman time so they're trying to push
it all back to the Ottomans as if
everything that happens was was the
fault of the Ottomans
um but that's how deep it goes in these
countries the hatred and the
misunderstanding of the history
the influence of Islam is not very big
however in the in the South where you
have the dobroja region you have
actually even moved here there is a
Mufti who is recognized by the
government and the Romanian government
nowadays has recognized 18 Fates 18
religions amongst the most of Islam so I
think this is quite
um
quite an important point to mention
Islam is also recognized in Greece and
also in Serbia
but the difference is that again because
of the minority being much smaller than
it is in Serbia in Greece or in Bulgaria
I think they're more open-minded and
don't regard Islam as being a threat
which might change if there are more if
there are more remaining Rivers who are
coming but yeah so
we heard this term for people who know a
little bit about history this term
Dracula there's been movies made about
him how did the people there now look at
this person this individual by the name
of Dracula okay excellent story because
it is really many people really when
they hear of Romania the first thing the
Mind goes straight to to to Vlad The
Count Dracula as he's called now we have
to see that certain legends that have
developed during history
um are nothing else but that Legends now
uh vampires I think we all agree don't
really exist right and what they have
come up with this uh the the story of
vampires which was developed in that
area in Romania and surroundings
um there was a once once this this
voivode the ruler of wallachia so as I
said before there are two uh there were
two principalities that actually have
become now a par Romania the country the
nation of Romania
um and walachi was one of the two and he
was the ruler of wallachia during the
15th century and in this 15th century
his name was Vlad and his title was
given was Vlad the Impaler vlate in
Romanian Vlad the Impaler Vlad Dracula
the dragon basically Dracula his father
had this name already he belonged to the
Brotherhood of of of the dragon and his
son went over with this name the Impaler
is a very important title that needs to
be explained and he was one of the
cruelest most probably rulers in Europe
especially in the Middle Ages especially
in the 15th century
um he used to impale his enemies uh I
don't know if you're aware of what it
actually means or maybe uh the audience
I don't know what if you can what
impaling means he used to take uh how
would you describe it and they Minister
he should take uh a poll and put it
through the the uh the rear the anus all
the way through towards the the neck
absolutely right absolutely I mean if
you why they were alive by the way while
they were alive a very important Point
while they were alive
um and one thing that is extremely
important to to see vlad's history Vlad
grew up or was for a longer period of
time uh at the at the ottoman Sultan's
court and his brother as well he had
another younger brother Radu and Radu
remained at the court of the Ottomans
and actually was very loyal towards the
Ottomans he himself was a Muslim his
brother his brother Radu
um Vlad Vlad the Impaler became he
wanted basically uh Power he wanted the
throne and for that reason he fought the
Ottomans and was going with whoever was
on his side once with the hungarians
then again again against the hungarians
the hungarians were that time a very big
force in the 15th century and they
fought the Ottomans so as soon as they
fought the Ottomans he was on their side
as soon as he fought the Ottomans they
were on his side so you understand when
they again attacked Transylvanian he
fought them so that was real politics
let's call it it is real politics and
it's in in in the 15th century
um and for Vlad it was really not
religion didn't play a role in that way
he was just whatever whatever he could
make use of was it the Orthodox Church
was it Islam was it the sultan he did he
spoke Turkish so he could actually also
um
um a fight the the Ottomans
um and pretend being an a Turkish Muslim
for example hiding amongst the people
and Escape for example so all these
things happened during his his lifetime
and the important thing with regards to
his title being the Impaler how all this
started the the hostility very strongly
from the time from the side of the
sultan Sultan Miami father by the way
the one who opened Constantinople and
the one who entered Athens as well so
Sultan was his biggest enemy although
they knew each other from before they
grew up together at the same court as
well started this whole hostility
because Vlad the Impaler when he was
sent
um two emissaries
ottoman
emissaries to to to give him a message
um he impaired he he told them to take
the turbans off and he knew that they
wouldn't do that they don't take him
that's not something they would do so he
actually nailed with three Nails each
one of them their turbans on their head
so he made them pay for not listening to
him next to this one he impaled them and
20 000 it said in the history books 20
000 Ottomans and other enemies uh
impaled them while alive
um all this if you think of it
subhanallah I think nowadays of course
we are not we cannot judge really how
people thought that time in the 14th
15th 16th centuries there were different
men thought different women thought
different they were also stronger uh for
sure I mean but imagine now I think
anybody can understand
um nailing the turban on somebody's head
while they're alive and impaling them
for their life this must be a terrible
situation and he was feared by many
people Muslims non-muslims
um enemies or friends alike
um and his his game was trying trying to
get the throne basically of Romania to
become the next Romanian Emperor or the
next Romanian leader and he had to fight
with the hungarians because they were
stronger power and also against them so
in in general the whole Dracula thing
came up because Bram Stoker who wrote
the novel Dracula he actually had heard
something about such a cruel person and
basically they even were saying that he
would drink
his enemy's blood that made him a
vampire basically so that's how this
whole thing started so he did exist
Count Dracula it did exist it was his
name coming from his father but he was
obviously not a vampire in the real
meaning of of the word uh um as we
imagined vampires nowadays what's the
association now current day with this
figure with the Orthodox Church have
they this is himself from him or did
they hold him up as an iconic figure
um you should we should never forget
that nowadays with nation states it's
different to that time when the church
churches were ruling actually nowadays
we have Nations Nation Orthodox Nations
such as Romania Serbia Bulgaria Greece
and they do have their own National
Orthodox Churches which means that the
church
is actually serving the nation
so whatever the Nations the nation
believes in and keeps up such as Vlad
being actually a national hero believe
it or not the Romanians consider him as
being being a national hero
so the church also supports the idea the
Orthodox Church supports such a cruel
man saying basically that he is one of
our national heroes so Romania the
Romanian Orthodox church and National
Church of Romania supports the man of
the 15th century who's considered a
Romanian hero who did these these these
cruel acts which are unbelievable
actually
and I just want to make a side note here
that this is something torture in this
sense is prohibited uh in Islam is that
correct
correct absolutely yes yeah this
inhumane torture this type is something
that is definitely
um something that is not part of Islam
and tell me this so if you have
so you answered my question
it's kind of odd that so this person
that um did this kind of horrific uh
these crimes today that we consider as
war crimes you know these just it just
uh this violent
um inhumane kind of uh what is this
called again
Act no no no this uh the the term in the
um stuffing this uh the swords or
through the anus up to the neck impaling
inhaling they're impaling okay to doing
this impaling and whatnot it's just uh
sick so they they look at him currently
as a um as a hero as somebody yeah
absolutely so then that would bring us
back to what we originally started now
so if you have uh a church and you have
people who look to this person as an
hero and they have this strong what
would be your opinion did Andrew Tate's
conversion to Islam after giving twenty
thousand dollars did he say a month
a month yes a month and uh being someone
who is an Orthodox Christian did this
now do you think this played a role in
him still being detained to this day
without any formal charges being held uh
captive in this uh Romanian jail did his
conversion and then him also walking
into the court with the Quran
Yes yes again he's he doesn't hide in
mashallah which is I mean may Allah give
him really reward the reward that he
deserves and may Allah make him strong
he needs this
[Music]
um
the I think it does play a role it does
play a role that he of course has left
the church
and that the church is not on his side
anymore that they would not support
lawyers they would not be on the on his
side that definitely plays a role why
are they keeping him for months I mean
we're talking about months now this is
not something that has been going on for
some days or a week or something it has
been going on for months I don't know
the exact time but it is months now it
has been going on and they're trying and
again they're keeping him we should not
forget Romania is part of the European
Union nowadays so in the European Union
country
okay with a very Progressive mindset as
they should as they say as they should
have
um they're keeping a man
in prison with no charges at all at
least for months
now this is absolutely against any
understanding of of a normal Humane
state of a progressive democracy as they
call themselves human rights
human rights absolutely what about all
that
um I don't think it's just Islam but it
did help it does help okay to make him
an unwanted figure to make him somebody
that people actually don't like many
women didn't like him before because
they called him misogynistic all the
stuff that came out about and rotate
which I don't even know if this is all
true but
um now it does not help of course him
being Muslim and supporting Islam and
being so outspoken about Islam as you
said yes he entered the cartoon the
Quran
and next to this one I think his brother
accepted the faith as well his brother
embraced Islam as well and a friend of
his recently so you know the influence
that he has on youngsters and young
people even in the UK and in the west
and in Europe
is amazing so this man opens the door
for youngsters in Europe and people who
like him to actually look into Islam at
least look into Islam and forget all the
Prejudice and all the
the negative ideas that we're going
around which is good for Islam and good
for us but not good for them obviously
and you would want somebody if somebody
had some some views you know of the past
or some things you you'd want because
Islam is the medicine Islam is going to
help you to go ahead and transform your
life so we saw that just weeks after
accepting Islam we give up alcohol his
good friend was saying that he talked to
him about the gambling he was going to
give up a lot of these signs for many
people this thing takes years right
these things but he was after weeks he
was starting to uh for the first time we
saw him apologizing for past comments
that he made
and we see him on a road to
transformation so it's a good thing
Islam will because we don't support any
of these things alcohol gambling these
only fans whatever these things are this
uh process you know whatever the all of
these uh evils out there in the world
Islam is against that so you need Islam
Islam helps you to transform for the
better is that
is that correct no of course no doubt
about it I mean what can I say I'm a
self-transformed since I became Muslim
for 30 years now alhamdulillah so I
myself come from that area again uh as
you mentioned I'm Greek and um I
understand fully uh the position of the
church in these kind of countries
um the position of the population that
were told myths and lies and legends and
all this they believe and they grow up
like this so you can't blame them
entirely the population but once you
must grow out of it as I did
alhamdulillah and you must question
certain things I think as a human being
living in the 21st century you should be
able to question and you should be able
to make a choice and Andrew Ted made
this choice and made his choice and I
think we should leave it to it and as
many others made other choices so I
don't think it should play a role but I
I do believe that it did play a role
that he did accept Islam and it didn't
make it more sympathetic towards the
west and towards other people who might
have been in between shall we support
them shall we not support him so many in
the end actually decided not to support
them that's it for people who want to
who are history fans and who want who
who like learning about history this is
your specialty where can people go you
have an Institute that we mentioned
earlier in this program and if people
want to learn more about the history in
this region and clear up any of the
misconceptions that people have in their
minds where can they go and visit to
learn more
is basically an Institute which we set
up in London two years ago we're now in
our second year and we are teaching the
students are interested Muslims and
non-muslims alike about this very
important work by even Haldol even
khaldoon was one of the biggest Scholars
actually of Islam in the 14th century 15
14th to 15th centuries and he wrote this
book al-mucadima so according to this we
call this program al-mucadima the monkey
program it's written without an age by
the way there is another website with an
h.com but we ours is al-mucadima without
nih.com
so there we will we will basically look
into his work which is a very important
work for the father of sociology as he
called in the west so even khaldoon is
considered the father of sociology so
we're looking into sociology political
science uh religious and Islamic Studies
we're looking into history and
historiography
um economics all this unbelievable
things all this in one book so I really
consider that a very important work and
we all Muslims and all Muslims should
actually know about him and by the way
Mark Zuckerberg was actually mentioning
in his book club so he wants his people
to read the mukadima in his book club
and we all know Mark Zuckerberg we know
he's not a historian so why would he
read such a book which is full of
Islamic elements and references to Islam
so it is very interesting indeed so I
really think that for anybody who's
interestedima.com without the age take a
look at our Institute take a look at
what we offer the program starts again
in September October with a new year Dr
surf thank you very much
brothers and sisters we've all had loved
ones that passed away a mother a father
a brother sister a close family member
but one of the mercies of our Dean is
that with the right intention we can go
ahead and continue to do good deeds on
our loved one's behalf and what greater
of a continuous Good Deeds
than investing on their behalf in the
dean Center and Masjid and megadawa
Center that will benefit generations to
come inshallah so click the link below
donate right now may God Almighty Allah
reward all of you I cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you are not yet
Muslim and you tune in to see what these
Muslims are talking about and you like a
free copy of the Quran go and visit
thedenshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
assalamualaikum